à présent nous allons réaliser notre
propre dentifrice bonjour astrid devant
jo wilfried oui effectivement je suis
allé chez valérie klein de l'association
very green à leur présenter ses recettes
de dentifrice et vous allez voir c'est
très simple je vais commencer par mettre
30 g de blanc de meudon dans un pot en
verre qui a été stérilisés ça c'est
important quand on fait des cosmétiques
à la maison d'abord on stérilise
toujours ces petits pots ses ustensiles
alors ensuite à ses 30 grammes il faut
ajouter 5 gouttes d'huile essentielle
ça peut être de là - de poivre et du
citron ou même du titre i qui lui est
ainsi antiseptiques et laure c'était
fini déjà on pourrait mais on peut aussi
ajouter des propriétés au dentifrice
on a tout un tas de propriété qu'on
trouve dans notamment dans les plantes
et des plantes
en fait on en a partout et elles sont
pleines de propriété donc c'est vraiment
très intéressant notamment
donc on a le thym et le romarin qui sont
des plantes antiseptique
antibactériennes alors il ya aussi la
sauge qui a un côté désinfectants et
cicatrisant le plantain ou encore lortie
qui elle est bien connue pour ses
vitamines c vitamine et son côté
minéralisant on peut faire un mix donc
de toutes ces plantes qu'on réduit en
poudre et donc ajouter 10 grammes de
cette poudre à la préparation on ajoute
un tout petit peu de bicarbonate de
soude sur une pointe de couteau par
exemple parce que ça permet de salive et
à ce niveau là votre recette de
dentifrice à les terminer
c'est à dire que vous prenez votre
brosse à dents vous trempez votre brosse
dans l'eau et vous là vous l'appliquez
comme ça sur la brosse à dents vous vous
brossez les dents avec ça alors valérie
conseils pour permettre une transition
plus facile entre le dentifrice du
commerce et les dentifrices maison
d'ajouter encore deux ingrédients pour
avoir un effet un peu plus pâteux comme
on al'habitude de la glycérine végétale
bio c'est très important et un peu d'eau
pour la glycérine
il faut pas dépasser 10% du grammage de
l'après de la préparation
donc si on a 40 g de préparation il faut
ajouter entre 3 et 4% de glycérine
enfin un peu de mathématiques pour pas
se tromper bien sûr merci beaucoup à ce
raid et pour ceux qui veulent revoir
aussi votre chronique sur comment
réaliser sa lessive maison rendez vous
sur notre site internet rubrique ripley
dans les archives de si on rentrait et
c'était également avec l'association
very green qu'on remercie